scarlett johansson makes a second i
think more interesting argument in her
suit against
disney she's claiming that disney
breached what's called the covenant of
good faith and fair dealing generally
the covenant of good faith and fair
dealing says that
apart from the actual language of the
contract you can't do things that uphold
the letter of the contract while
frustrating the intent of the contract
so for example if i was going to enter a
new contract to sell all apple computers
and then i wanted to backup the contract
and
i just rebranded all my computers
schmapple computers and said well
look we don't make apple computers
anymore we only make shmapples well
that might not be an actual breach of
the language of the contract but you can
see that that
violates the covenant of good faith and
fair dealing that's what scarjo says
happened with disney scarlett johansson
only made extra money based on the
theatrical release and
if they're going to release this thing
on disney plus where they make 60
million dollars instead of the 20
million dollars well then she doesn't
see any value to that and that
frustrates the covenant of good faith
and fair dealing this could potentially
be a better argument than her pure
breach of contract claim but regardless
we'll see them in court